SENATE. COMMITTEE ON LABOR.
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
WILL COME TO ORDER. HAPPY
JUNETEENTH, EVERYONE. GOOD
MORNING, WE ARE PREPARED FOR OUR
FIRST PRESENTER WHO I SEE IN THE
ROOM, ASSEMBLYWOMAN AGUILAR.
CARRIE DO YOU WANT TO COME
FORWARD? WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE THIS MORNING
AS WE WAIT FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
GET US TO A QUORUM. I'LL TAKE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE, AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT. ANOTHER DAY IN
PARADISE. OH. IT'S FINE. GOOD
MORNING, SENATORS. EDUCATORS
CANNOT CURRENTLY EARN PAID
PREGNANCY LEAVE. ONLY AFTER THEY
HAVE USED ALL THEIR SICK LEAVE.
OUR EDUCATORS ABLE TO RECEIVE
DIFFERENTIAL PAY WHEN THEY
CANNOT WORK DUE TO PREGNANCY
RELATED DISABILITIES.
DIFFERENTIAL PAY IS A FANCY WAY
OF SAYING YOU GET TO PAY FOR
YOUR SUBSTITUTE. OTHER TYPES OF
LEAVE CITED BY THE OPPOSITION AS
PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE
ALTERNATIVES ARE UNPAID
EDUCATORS. THEY SAY, CAN
SCHEDULE THEIR PREGNANCIES BASED
ON THEIR SCHOOL CALENDAR OR JUST
FOR FOREGO PAY. FOR ANY OF YOU
WHO ARE PARENTS, I'M SURE YOU
KNOW WELL, SCHEDULING
PREGNANCIES DOESN'T WORK IN REAL
LIFE AS WE ARE TRYING TO JOIN
THE REST OF THE WORLD IN
PROVIDING EMPLOYEES RIGHTS TO
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WHY ARE
EDUCATORS TREATED THE WORST
SINCE THIS LEGISLATION WAS LAST
PROPOSED? DATA FROM CALSTRS
SHOWS THAT WOMEN WILL RECEIVE
ALMOST $100,000 LESS IN
RETIREMENT BENEFITS THAN THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS IN A IN A
PROFESSION WHERE OVER 70% ARE
WOMEN. THIS IS SHOCKING AND
UNACCEPTABLE. IT IS A SYSTEMIC
SEXISM, AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
ALL TRY TO FIX THIS. MEANWHILE,
WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH CRITICAL
SHORTAGES IN THE VERY
PROFESSIONS WE ARE TRYING TO
HELP WITH. THIS BILL CAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DATA
SHOWS THAT THERE WERE MORE THAN
10,000 VACANCIES IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BY THE END OF
2022, AND WE HAVE NOT RECOVERED.
FIXING THIS INEQUITY IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS ADDRESSING
THE STAFFING AND RETIREMENT
ISSUES, AS WE DO OUR BEST TO
INVEST IN OUR YOUTH AND THEIR
EDUCATION AND TRY TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO JOIN THE MOST
IMPORTANT PROFESSION. SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT WITH ME TODAY WILL
BE, IS SETH BRAMBLE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, AND WE ARE
EXPECTING STATE SUPERINTENDENT
TONY THURMOND AS WELL. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH YOUR TESTIMONY, I
WOULD LIKE TO GET OUR QUORUM
PULLED TOGETHER. JUST GIVE US A
MOMENT. ASSISTANT, WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLE? ALL RIGHT, SMALL
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS HERE.
WILK WILK. PRESENT. CORTEZ
GONZALEZ. LAIRD. LAIRD HERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I SEE OUR SPECIAL
GUEST HAS ARRIVED. WELCOME,
SUPERINTENDENT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS BEFORE WE
MOVE TO THE FIRST WITNESS? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS.
TONY THURMOND, STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, HONORED TO BE A
SPONSOR. AND HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2901, I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD, THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IN SUPPORTING
OUR WORKFORCE, RETENTION, AND
EQUITY, BECAUSE THE CURRENT
PRACTICE REQUIRES, WOMEN
EDUCATORS TO DEPLETE THEIR SICK
LEAVE TIME, THEY ALSO FIND
THEMSELVES, LOSING RETIREMENT
CREDITS WHEN IT COMES TIME TO
RETIRE, AS COMPARED TO THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS, THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BY OUR EDUCATORS, TO
GIVE THEM PAID SICK LEAVE FOR,
PAID PREGNANCY LEAVE FOR UP TO
14 WEEKS, AND TO CORRECT AN
INEQUITY THAT EXISTS IN OUR
SYSTEM AND TO ALLOW US TO DO
BETTER ON RETENTION AS WE
STRUGGLE TO WORK THROUGH, A
TEACHER SHORTAGE, THIS WOULD DO
GREAT THINGS FOR CLASSROOM
TEACHERS, CLASSIFIED STAFF, AND
THOSE IN HIGHER ED. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2901. YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. SUPERINTENDENT, AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
SETH BROUGH SPEAKING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
ALONGSIDE OUR, SUPERINTENDENT
AND THE STATE TREASURER AND THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS, AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT, A STUDY BY THE
INTERNATIONAL LABOR ORGANIZATION
OF THE UNITED NATIONS FOUND
THERE'S BEEN A GRADUAL SHIFT,
ACROSS THE GLOBE TOWARDS
PREGNANCY LEAVE PERIODS THAT
MEET OR EXCEED A MINIMUM
STANDARD OF 14 WEEKS, WHEN
LEAVES TO SHORT, MOTHERS MAY NOT
FEEL READY TO RETURN TO WORK AND
MAY DROP OUT OF THE WORKFORCE,
THE STUDY POINTS OUT, OUT OF THE
167 COUNTRIES STUDIED, 97% DO
PROVIDE THIS PAID LEAVE FOR
WOMEN. ONLY FOUR OF 167
COUNTRIES DID NOT. LESOTHO PAPUA
NEW GUINEA, SWAZILAND, AND THE
UNITED STATES. IN CALIFORNIA,
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
WORLDWIDE, ONE OF THE LARGEST
AND PREDOMINANTLY FEMALE
WORKFORCES IN THE STATE, ARE
EXCLUDED FROM PREGNANCY. LEAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL STANDARD FOR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS IN MOST
COUNTRIES ACROSS THE GLOBE. AS
OF 2020, IRELAND PROVIDED
WORKERS WITH SIX AND A HALF
MONTHS OF PAID LEAVE. ITALY
PROVIDED FIVE MONTHS OF PAID
LEAVE, ENGLAND PROVIDED NEARLY
TEN MONTHS OF PAID LEAVE, AND
SWEDEN NEARLY 16 MONTHS OF PAID
LEAVE. CALIFORNIA IS FAR BEHIND
THE WORLD IN THIS AREA, AND AS
WE EMBRACE DIVERSITY AND FAMILY
FRIENDLY POLICIES IN OUR STATE,
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING MORE EQUITY TO RETIREMENT
INCOME. THE PROPOSED NEW
PREGNANCY LEAVE FOR EDUCATORS
WILL NOT BE DEDUCTED FROM SICK
LEAVE AND IMPROVE WORKING
CONDITIONS TO HELP ATTRACT AND
RETAIN TALENTED EDUCATORS. AS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED, MORE THAN
THREE QUARTERS OF EDUCATORS ARE
FEMALE, MAKING THIS PROPOSED
POLICY ESPECIALLY IMPACTFUL FOR
THOSE WHO CHOOSE PUBLIC
EDUCATION. FOR THEIR CAREER. WE
THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR
HER LEADERSHIP AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS AND
STAFF MITCH STEIGER WITH CFT, A
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. ALSO
IN SUPPORT OR PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR, URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KIM
LEWIS REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW.
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, KATHY MCBRIDE, ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, IN
SUPPORT MARTIN RADOSEVICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION AND
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, SHANE GUSMAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, IN
SUPPORT. MARIKO YOSHIHARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION,
IN SUPPORT JOHN MEREDITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM, IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE? OKAY?
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? THEIR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. PLEASE IS
THERE A LEAD WITNESS FOR
OPPOSITION? NO. OKAY, SURE.
ELIZABETH ESQUIVEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2901. SO WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR FOR
GRANTING EMPLOYEE LEAVE FOR THE
PURPOSES FOR THESE PURPOSES. AND
OUR CONCERN REALLY STEMS FROM
THE FISCAL IMPACT THAT IT WILL
HAVE ON LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND THE COMPLEXITY
COMPLEXITY IT WOULD ADD TO THE
ALREADY COMPLICATED SET OF STATE
AND FEDERAL EMPLOYEE LEAVE
PROGRAMS. AB 2901 WOULD INCREASE
THE FINANCIAL PRESSURES ON
SCHOOLS WITHOUT A CORRESPONDING
BUDGET APPROPRIATION TO COVER
THE NEW BENEFIT AND MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS DOES
CREATE AN UNFUNDED MANDATE WITH
AN ESTIMATED COST OF TENS TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN THESE
VARIOUS LEAVE RELATED STATUTORY
PROVISIONS HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX, AND WE
MUST CONSIDER THE IMPACT ON OUR
ABILITY TO FULLY STAFF
CLASSROOMS AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING A TEACHER SHORTAGE.
WE BELIEVE FURTHER DECISIONS
REGARDING LEAVE POLICIES FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE BEST
RESOLVED THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. DOROTHY JOHNSON WITH
THE ACSA, THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN THE MAJORITY
OF MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM KASBO, BUT DEFINITELY WANT
TO, DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT. WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THE CONCEPT OF GIVING
LEAVE FOR THESE CRITICAL NEEDS,
WHETHER IT'S FAMILY CARE,
PERSONAL CARE, AND SO FORTH.
WHAT WE DO, OF COURSE, DEEPLY
WORRY ABOUT IS THE IMMENSE COST
PRESSURE FOR FUNDS THAT ARE
ALREADY DEDICATED TO STUDENTS,
CLASSROOMS AND TEACHER AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF SALARY AND
BENEFITS. SO AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STAFF SHORTAGES. WE THINK
THIS IS ONE PIECE OF A MUCH
BROADER PUZZLE AND MUST BE
DISCUSSED IN THAT CONTEXT AND
NOT TAKEN ALONE, GIVEN AGAIN,
THE IMMENSE COST PRESSURES AND
THE VACANCIES THAT WILL BE LEFT
FOR OUR REMAINING STAFF TO BEAR
THE BURDEN AND CARRY ON TO MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS AND OTHER
STUDENT SERVICES ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME TO THE
MIC. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. NICK BROMLEY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO IN THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, WANT
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
KOSOVO AND AXA IN PARTICULAR,
THE CONCERNS AROUND CONTINUITY
OF INSTRUCTION AS WE LOOK AT
SUBSTITUTES ROTATING IN AND OUT
OF THE CLASSROOM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH ACME. WE
ARE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT. FORGIVE
US FOR BEING OUT OF ORDER. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE?
OKAY SEEING NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION MEMBERS. SURE. SEN
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SURE I
SUPPORT THE GENERAL DIRECTION OF
THIS, AND WE'LL VOTE TO MOVE IT.
BUT WE HAVE A CHART IN OUR
ANALYSIS THAT COMPARES, FMLA,
PREGNANCY, DISABILITY LEAVE,
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS ACT TO
THIS, THE PROVISIONS IN THOSE
ACTS TO THIS BILL, FOR EXAMPLE.
WELL, IT SAYS EMPLOYEE
ELIGIBILITY AND FOR A COUPLE OF
THEM IT SAYS WORKED 1250 HOURS
IN THE PRIOR 12 MONTHS. AND FOR
THIS BILL, IT SAYS UNSPECIFIED
AND FOR CONTINUED HEALTH
COVERAGE, MOST OF THEM SAY YES
IN THIS BILL. IT SAYS
UNSPECIFIED ADD IN THE LENGTH OF
LEAVE IT GENERALLY SAYS 12
MONTHS OR UP TO FOUR MONTHS, BUT
THIS IS MORE OPEN ENDED AND
DETERMINED BY EMPLOYEE AND
PHYSICIAN. AND SO AND SOME OF
THEM ARE UNPAID, ACTUALLY
MAJORITY ARE UNPAID. AND THEN
THE OTHERS PARTIAL WAGE. THIS IS
FULL PAY. SO THIS IS HASN'T TIED
DOWN SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
OTHER BILLS TIED DOWN DO YOU
INTEND TO DO THAT AS THIS
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD. WELL
OBVIOUSLY THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW
I COULD HAVE MISSED THAT, BUT,
I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO IT AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE BILL. WELL, IT'S I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT I WOULD
HOPE FOR A LITTLE MORE OF A
COMMITMENT THAT YOU WILL
ACTUALLY SPECIFY PLACES WHERE
IT'S UNSPECIFIED TIED SO THAT
THAT WE HAVE A WAY THAT THIS
WILL ALIGN WITH THE OTHER, LAWS
THAT WE HAVE. I THINK THE CHART
WAS WAS VERY INSTRUCTIVE AND
VERY CLEAR, AS IS DESCRIBED IN
THE CHART, AND AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, THE OTHER LEAVES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE ARE UNPAID. IN
GENERAL, EDUCATORS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE. I KNOW THERE WAS A
MENTION IN THE ANALYSIS THAT LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED, DOES. JUST TO
BE CLEAR, THEY HAVE A LOT OF
BARGAINING UNITS IN LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED. THE MEMBERS OF UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES DO NOT HAVE
THE 30,000 OR SO EDUCATORS THAT
WE HAVE REPRESENT, DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE, BUT THE INTENT HERE,
IN TERMS OF EMPLOYEE ELIGIBILITY
IS THAT ANY CERTIFICATE OR
CLASSIFIED STAFF COULD TAKE THIS
LEAVE IF THEY WERE, ESSENTIALLY,
PREGNANT, GOING THROUGH THE
CONDITIONS OF PREGNANCY. SO
THERE'S NOT A PRIOR AMOUNT OF
HOURS THAT'S REQUIRED IN TERMS
OF CONTINUED HEALTH COVERAGE IN
GENERAL, IF YOU'RE ON PAID
LEAVE, THAT MEAN THAT IF
SOMEBODY HAS WORKED FOR TWO
HOURS, THEY IMMEDIATELY ARE
ELIGIBLE. THE SAME IS ACTUALLY
TRUE FOR SICK LEAVE. SO WHEN YOU
START AS A TEACHER AND SICK
LEAVE DAY ONE, YOU HAVE TEN DAYS
THAT YOU CAN USE IF YOU GET
SICK. THE SAME IS INTENDED FOR
THIS, LEAVE THAT IF YOU GOT
PREGNANT. THAT'S TOTALLY
APPRECIATED. IT'S JUST THAT THAT
TEN DAYS IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN THAN THE LENGTH OF THIS,
WHICH IS MUCH, MUCH LONGER AFTER
SOMEBODY WORKING FOR TWO DAYS.
IT DEPENDS. IT'S BETWEEN THE
DOCTOR AND THE PATIENT. BUT
CERTAINLY IT COULD BE UP TO A
PERIOD OF 14 WEEKS OF PAID
LEAVE. BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR
SECOND QUESTION, CONTINUED
HEALTH COVERAGE, GENERALLY, IF
YOU'RE ON A PAID LEAVE, YOU DO
HAVE ACCESS TO CONTINUED HEALTH
COVERAGE. BUT AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, IF THERE'S
A NEED TO CLARIFY THAT, I THINK
THAT'S OKAY. I, I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR I DON'T GUESS I'LL SEE THIS
AGAIN UNTIL IT'S ON THE FLOOR,
BUT I'M JUST LOOKING FOR ALL
THESE ISSUES TO BE RESOLVED. BUT
BY THE TIME IT GETS THERE, YOU
GOT IT. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH. AND I'LL COME VISIT
YOU ONE ON ONE AND MAKE SURE WE
HAVE IT CLARIFIED. AND YOU KNOW,
MAYBE IN THE CHART YOU NEED TO
ADD A COLUMN ON WHETHER OR NOT
PEOPLE ARE COVERED WITH
DISABILITY OR NOT. SO IT PUTS
INTO CONTEXT WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
SPECIFIED OR UNSPECIFIED. BUT
THAT'S NEITHER HERE NOR THERE. I
DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU HOW TO
BEST ADVOCATE FOR YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD, ANYONE ELSE? DO
WE HAVE A WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAIRD,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE COLLEAGUES? LET'S FACE IT,
WE'RE LOSING TEACHERS FASTER
THAN WE CAN EDUCATE THEM. IT'S
TIME TO STOP CHARGING WOMEN
$100,000 TO CARE FOR THEIR
CHILD. WHILE WE AWAIT THEIR
RETURN TO CARE FOR OURS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
VOTE THANK YOU. AND, SISTER,
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL ON? FINAL
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 2901. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK. CORTES CORTEZ I.
GONZALEZ LAIRD I LAIRD I. WITH A
VOTE OF 3 TO 0, THIS BILL WILL
BE ON CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. WHILE THE NEXT
PERSON'S COMING UP, I WOULD MOVE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, WHICH IS THE
ENTIRE CONSENT AGENDA. THANK YOU
FOR THAT MOTION, SISTER. CALL
THE ROLL, PLEASE. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS A
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. SENATOR.
WILK. SENATOR CORTEZ. CORTEZ.
AYE. SENATOR. GONZALEZ SENATOR.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. WITH A VOTE
OF 3 TO 0, THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ON CALL.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA IN THE ROOM. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE ORDER,
AND THAT IS FILE ORDER NUMBER
ONE AB TWO 288. HELLO WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU MAY PROCEED
. SENATORS. THERE IT IS, AB 2288
WOULD ALLOW COURTS TO ORDER
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IN A PAGA
CLAIM. SINCE 2004, PAGA HAS
SERVED AS A CRITICAL ENFORCEMENT
TOOL OF CALIFORNIA'S LABOR LAWS,
RECOGNIZING THE REALITY THAT
STATE'S LABOR ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES OFTEN LACK THE
RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE AND
TAKE ACTION AGAINST EVERY
VIOLATION, PAGA CASES ARE MOST
OFTEN FILED TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
LABOR CODE VIOLATIONS AND
ENFORCE FUNDAMENTAL LABOR RIGHTS
SUCH AS OVERTIME, MINIMUM WAGE,
AND SICK LEAVE. UNFORTUNATELY,
CALIFORNIA IS IN A LABOR
ENFORCEMENT CRISIS. A FEBRUARY
2024 REPORT BY THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER HIGHLIGHTED NEARLY
600,000 WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE A WAGE VIOLATION
TOTALING ALMOST $2 BILLION IN
LOSSES ANNUALLY. ONLY 2% OF
THOSE LOST WAGES ARE RECOVERED
BY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S WAGE
CLAIM PROCESS. LIMITED PUBLIC
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES. FORCED
ARBITRATION HAVE SEVERELY
LIMITED WORKERS OPTIONS TO SEEK
RECOURSE, MAKING REMEDIES LIKE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF NEEDED TO
STRENGTHEN PACA'S EFFECTIVENESS
IN THE CONTEXT OF PAGA,
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF WOULD ENABLE
COURTS TO ORDER EMPLOYEES TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGES IN THE
WORKPLACE. FOR EXAMPLE, IF AN
EMPLOYER FAILS TO PROVIDE
WORKERS WITH PAID SICK DAYS, THE
COURT COULD ORDER AN INJUNCTION
REQUIRING THE EMPLOYER TO
ESTABLISH A LAWFUL PAID SICK DAY
POLICY. PAGA REMAINS ONE OF THE
ONLY TOOLS WORKERS HAVE TO
REMEDY VIOLATIONS OF THEIR
RIGHTS, AND AB 2288 IS ABOUT
ENSURING THEY SEE COMPREHENSIVE,
MEANINGFUL RELIEF FROM UNLAWFUL
WORKPLACE PRACTICES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS SARAH
FLOX, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
THANK YOU MAY PROCEED. MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS SARAH FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, OUR
GOAL WITH ANY CHANGES TO PAGA IS
TO CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
EMPLOYERS TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE AND TO FOLLOW THE
LAW. THE GOAL REALLY IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
ABLE TO FOLLOW THE LAW, AND
WORKERS HAVE THAT REDRESS.
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS. IT MEANS THAT IF AN
EMPLOYER HAD BEEN MISCLASSIFYING
WORKERS, THAT THEN RATHER THAN
JUST PAYING A SETTLEMENT, THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY RECLASSIFY THOSE
WORKERS SO THEY WOULD HAVE ALL
OF THE PROTECTIONS FOR THE LABOR
OF THE LABOR CODE, THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF ANY
CHANGES THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD
ON PAGA. AND WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES? OKAY SO ME TOO.
THOSE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE COME TO
THE MIC. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. MARIKO
YOSHIHARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION, THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA, AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WORKER
POWER IN SUPPORT SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS
LOUIE COSTA SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION, STATE LEGISLATIVE
BOARD IN SUPPORT. BRIAN
MIRAMONTEZ WITH ASMI,
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE HERE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION IN, GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. ASHLEY
HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
AS THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY, THERE WILL BE A BILL
GOING INTO PRINT, THAT DOES HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM, WHICH WILL
INCLUDE A PIECE RELATED TO
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION IN
ISOLATION ABOUT INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF IS REALLY NO LONGER
RELEVANT, AS THAT THAT BILL WILL
GO INTO PRINT, SO RESPECTFULLY,
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. SENATORS DEAN GARFIELD
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SKYLER.
MONICA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS. MARLON
LARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. SARAH
PALERMO WITH CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MICHELI, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. ALSO, MY COLLEAGUE
BEN EBCLC ASKED ME TO EXPRESS
THE OPPOSITION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PROCESSORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
SABRINA LOCKHART WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. DARBY KERNAN, ON BEHALF
OF REDHEUGH AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AND HOPEFUL THAT THE
DEAL WILL ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS AND REALLY SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WOULD JUST SAY VERY
EUPHEMISTICALLY, I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THIS BILL WILL HARMONIZE
ITSELF WITH CURRENT EVENTS, AND
I MOVE THE BILL. DITTO. WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR. WELL, WE
ARE READY TO CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND YES TO THE SENATOR
LEADER'S POINT AND COMMENTS FROM
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. OBVIOUSLY,
I THINK WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE
WAS A DEAL STRUCK. IT'S VERY
FRESH AND NEW AND I THINK AT
THIS POINT, HAVING THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD UNTIL THOSE DETAILS
ARE FINALIZED IS VERY IMPORTANT.
I AM VERY HOPEFUL AND AS ARE THE
SPONSORS, THAT, THAT LARGER DEAL
WILL RESOLVE THE ISSUES IN THIS
LEGISLATION. BUT UNTIL, THE INK
IS DRY, SO TO SPEAK, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RELIEF CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD, BUT HOPEFUL FOR A
VERY POSITIVE RESOLUTION,
ULTIMATELY AND RESPECTFULLY, ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE TO ALLOW THE
CONVERSATIONS TO CONTINUE. WELL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS, FOR
EVERYONE'S HARD WORK ON THIS,
FOR BRINGING CALIFORNIA TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MOMENT. AND WITH
THAT, I WILL ASK THE ASSISTANT
TO CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
ONE AB 2288. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I. GONZALEZ
LAIRD. LAIRD I. THIS BILL IS HAS
A VOTE OF 3 TO 0. WE'LL PUT IT
ON CALL. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL
MOVE TO YOUR NEXT ITEM. AB 2602.
THANK YOU, AB 2602 WOULD REQUIRE
A PERFORMER'S INFORMED CONSENT
AND PROPER REPRESENTATION WHEN
EXECUTING A CONTRACT FOR ANY
TRANSFER OF RIGHTS SO THAT
INDIVIDUAL'S LIKENESS OR VOICE.
AMIDST THE RISE OF THE DIGITAL
AGE, PERFORMERS ACROSS THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY BEEN SIGNING AWAY
THEIR RIGHTS TO THEIR DIGITAL
SELVES THROUGH CLAUSES THAT CAN
LOOK LIKE STANDARD COPYRIGHT
LANGUAGE. SPECIFICALLY,
INDIVIDUALS ARE UNKNOWINGLY
AUTHORIZING STUDIOS TO USE THEIR
VOICE AND LIKENESS IN ALL MEDIA
BY ALL CURRENT AND FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES, IN PERPETUITY, AND
WITH NO ADDITIONAL COMPENSATION.
AB 2602 STRIKES THE BALANCE
BETWEEN INDUSTRY PROGRESS AND
PROTECTING A PERFORMER'S RIGHT
TO THEIR DIGITAL SELF AND
LIVELIHOOD. THIS BILL DOES NOT
OUTRIGHT PROHIBIT THE USE OF
DIGITAL REPLICAS, BUT RATHER
ENSURES THAT IF PERFORMERS AGREE
TO LICENSE OUT THEIR DIGITAL
SELF THAT THEY'RE FULLY AWARE OF
THE EXTENT OF AND THE INTENTIONS
FOR THAT USE, I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE MOTION PICTURES
ASSOCIATION AND RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS SHANE
GUZMAN. ON BEHALF OF SAG-AFTRA
AND SARAH FOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, SHANE
GUZMAN, ON BEHALF OF SAG-AFTRA
AND OUR 160,000 MEMBERS THAT ARE
PERFORMERS IN A VARIETY OF
ASPECTS OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY, THEY ARE VERY, VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THIS
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
GROWING EXPONENTIALLY FAST AND
IS GETTING BETTER AND CHEAPER TO
USE. I THINK A LOT OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ARE TALKING ABOUT AI
AND SIMILAR TECHNOLOGIES AND NOT
WANTING TO GET IN A PLACE WHERE
YOU'RE BLOCKING THE DEVELOPMENT
OF HELPFUL TECHNOLOGY, BUT AT
LEAST PUTTING SOME GUARDRAILS
AROUND THE POTENTIAL HARMS THAT
COULD HAPPEN. AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IT JUST
DEFINES WHAT INFORMED CONSENT
IS. IT FOLLOWS ALONG OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT,
THE LANGUAGE THERE AND WE TOO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE MPAA AND
THE RECORDING INDUSTRY FOR
NEGOTIATING WITH US AND GETTING
TO A PLACE WHERE EVERYBODY'S
GOOD WITH THIS BILL. SO WITH
THAT, ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. NEXT
WITNESS, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBER
SARA FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. WE'RE ALSO A
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
IT'S PART OF A BILL PACKAGE WE
HAVE OF FIVE BILLS TO PUT WORKER
CENTER GUARDRAILS ON THE USE OF
AI AND TECHNOLOGY IN THE
WORKPLACE. THIS BILL IS A GREAT
MODEL BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT
WORKERS HAVE REPRESENTATION WHEN
THEY ARE ENTERING INTO THESE
CONTRACTS ON THE MOST PERSONAL
AND ESSENTIAL ASSET THAT THEY
HAVE, WHICH IS THEIR LIKENESS
IS, AND SO THIS IS REALLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD. IT'S
A GREAT MODEL. AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL THEIR WORK, FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS BILL. ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IN THE ROOM? I'M OKAY
SEEING NONE. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
DÍAS MEMBERS. WELL, I WANT TO
JUST THANK YOU, FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT SAG-AFTRA AND MPAA
HAVE DONE. THE WRITERS GUILD ON
THIS ISSUE, AS WE'RE INTEGRATING
THIS TECHNOLOGY INTO OUR WORK
SITES, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE
DO IT PROTECTING HUMAN ASSETS.
AND I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES OF THAT, THAT WE ALL
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO. AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU. AND, THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT WENT INTO
THIS, DID YOU WANT TO YOU WILL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH, SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU.
ATTENDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK,
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. I GONZALEZ.
LAIRD. LAIRD I. WITH A VOTE OF 3
TO 0, THIS BILL IS ON CALL. I
THINK. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, FOR YOUR PATIENCE
. WE'LL NOW HEAR YOUR BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2873. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THE ANALYSIS
OUTLINED QUITE WELL WHAT AB 2873
DOES. SO I WILL, DEFER TO OUR
WITNESSES. ISIS ORELLANA POLICY
ANALYST FOR CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION, AND JENNIFER KERR,
A ENGLISH LANGUAGE INSTRUCTOR AT
THE GOODWILL OF SAN FRANCISCO
BAY. IN ESSENCE, WE'RE BRINGING
BACK A BILL FROM 2017 TO BE MORE
INTENTIONAL WITH OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS THESE
WORKFORCE DOLLARS AND ACHIEVE
THEIR GOALS OF EMPLOYMENT. AND
SO I'LL DEFER TO OUR WITNESSES
TO TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT THE
BILL AND THE IMPACTS OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TODAY. MY NAME
IS ISIS MEDINA ARIANA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
. AND I'M HERE TO DISCUSS AB
2073 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
AB 2073 SEEKS TO MAKE SMALL BUT
IMPACTFUL CHANGES TO ENHANCE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE BREAKING
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE OF. AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL, BREAKING BARRIERS
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
PARTNERS LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THEIR LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO TARGETED
POPULATIONS WHO HISTORICALLY
HAVE DIFFICULTIES IN OBTAINING
AND RETAINING EMPLOYMENT. IN THE
SEVEN YEARS SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION, BREAKING BARRIERS HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN CONNECTING
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT, EDUCATION
, AND TRAINING FOR
SELF-SUFFICIENCY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. THE BREAKING BARRIERS
PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS IN DEMAND
PROGRAM ENROLLMENT AND SOON TO
EXCEED 8000 INDIVIDUALS SERVED
THROUGH 68 GRANTS. THE PROGRAM
HAS OVERWHELMING INTEREST,
EVIDENCED BY 193 PROSPECTIVE
GRANTEES SEEKING A TOTAL OF $97
MILLION IN FUNDING, A STAGGERING
$58.8 MILLION MORE THAN WHAT WAS
MADE AVAILABLE. THE HIGH LEVEL
OF INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM HAS
HAD THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF CREATING A BURDEN ON BOTH
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS AND CBOS.
WHILE THESE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS AND CBOS
REMAIN A CRITICAL PIECE TO THE
BREAKING BARRIERS PROGRAM, WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN SOME
INSTANCES, THE POPULARITY PAIRED
WITH TIMELINES CREATED BY THE
GRANT HAVE CREATED BOTTLENECKS,
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALLER CBOS
ATTEMPTING TO FORMALIZE THESE
PARTNERSHIPS. THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE PROGRAM
MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE EQUITABLE,
FLEXIBLE, AND ACCESSIBLE, ALL
WHILE MAINTAINING THE PROGRAM'S
INTENDED GOALS. WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE AYE
ON AB 2073. THANK YOU MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
JENNIFER KERR AND I REPRESENT
GOODWILL OF THE SF BAY, WHERE I
WORK AS AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTOR. I'M HERE TO SHARE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM. GOODWILL OF THE SF BAY
IS A MISSION DRIVEN, COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT HELPS
THOSE WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT TO SECURE MEANINGFUL
WORK. OUR ORGANIZATION APPLIED
FOR AND RECEIVED FUNDING FROM
THE BREAKING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE TO CREATE
A PROGRAM THAT INCREASES ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY AND
IMPROVED JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE WITHIN OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM
QUALITY JOBS. LAST YEAR, WE
ENROLLED A WOMAN NAMED ANNIE,
WHO WAS REFERRED TO US BY
ANOTHER CBO. AFTER ARRIVING TO
THE USA. IT TOOK ANNIE MANY
YEARS FOR HER RIGHT TO WORK
DOCUMENTS TO ARRIVE, AND WHILE
WAITING, SHE BECAME AN IMPORTANT
PART OF HER NEW COMMUNITY.
THROUGH VOLUNTEER WORK AT THE
YMCA FOR HER CHURCH AND THE
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
GROUP. IN 2023, SHE RECEIVED HER
WORK AUTHORIZATION, BUT SHE WAS
WORRIED THAT HER LEVEL OF
ENGLISH COMPETENCY WOULD BE A
BARRIER. SHE WAS REALLY NERVOUS
TO SPEAK ENGLISH AT JOB
INTERVIEWS, SO SHE ENROLLED IN
GOODWILL'S JOB COACHING FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
COURSE, WHERE I TAUGHT HER HOW
TO CREATE A STRONG RESUME,
SEARCH FOR JOBS AND SUCCEED IN
AN INTERVIEW. AND IN JUST A FEW
WEEKS, ANNIE SECURED A POSITION
AS A CHILD CARE ASSISTANT WITH
CHI MING, A NONPROFIT, COMMUNITY
BASED AGENCY. HER STORY
EXEMPLIFIES THE WAYS IN WHICH
THE BREAKING BARRIERS INITIATIVE
. ALLOWS US TO EMPOWER LEARNERS
TO BREAK DOWN THE BARRIERS THAT
HAVE BARRED THEM FROM ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY. BUT THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT SOLELY ABOUT EMPLOYMENT. IT
IS ALSO ABOUT RESTORING DIGNITY
AND PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD STRONGER COMMUNITIES.
ANNIE IS JUST ONE OF THE STORIES
I COULD SHARE. WE HAVE ENROLLED
275 PEOPLE LIKE ANNIE INTO OUR
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS STORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. HI KRISTEN GORI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT.
DARBY KERNAN ON BEHALF OF
REDIFF, IN SUPPORT. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. OKAY. ANYONE IN
SPEAKING? JUST IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE, MOVE TO
THE DÍAS MEMBERS. MOVE AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM, SENATOR LAIRD.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH SORRY. YOU NEED. HE DOES GET
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. I'M SO
EXCITED ABOUT MAKING SURE WE
MOVE THE BREAKING BARRIERS BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
THAT. WITH THE CLOSED, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB 2873. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GONZALEZ. LAIRD LAIRD I THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A VOTE.
3 TO 0. THIS BILL IS ON CALL.
OKAY. WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
PRESENTERS HERE IN OUR LABOR
COMMITTEE ROOM 113 IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. ANY PRESENTERS IN THE
BUILDING, PLEASE HEAD OVER. WE
ARE READY TO START.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON IN THE HOUSE, WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO AB 2696.
AND YOU ARE PRESENTING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT, THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF SPEAKER MEREDITH
ANTHONY RENDON. ASSEMBLY BILL
2696 CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS GENERAL CONTRACTORS TO
AVOID WAGE LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
THEY COMPLETE PROJECTS WITH
THEIR OWN PERSONNEL, RATHER THAN
SUBCONTRACTING. CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS FOR FEDERALLY CERTIFIED,
JOINT, CERTIFIED JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE, OR THE LMC
TO HAVE DIRECT ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR SUBCONTRACTORS.
WAGE VIOLATIONS. DESPITE THIS,
THE LMC LOSES THEIR ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES WHEN A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR USES THEIR OWN
WORKFORCE CONTRACTS OR
CONSTRUCTIONS WORKERS. INSTEAD
OF SUBCONTRACTING IT OUT. AB
2696 CLOSES THE LOOPHOLE IN
EXTENDING LAW BY EXTENDING LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO INCLUDE DIRECT
ENFORCEMENT ON SELF-PERFORMING
GENERAL CONTRACTORS HERE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES, ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED BY DANNY KURT,
DIRECTOR, AND ALSO PATTI
MCCARRON, KAREN MCCARRON
MCCARRON, DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS. OKAY, THANKS SO
MUCH, ASSEMBLYMAN, AND THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING. APPRECIATE IT.
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, I JUST
WANT TO GO OVER THIS QUICKLY. I
KNOW YOU GOT A LOT, A LOT GOING
ON, NOT JUST HERE, BUT ACROSS
THE BOARD. THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS, AS MOST OF THE THINGS
WE DO HERE ARE NEVER GET QUITE
GET IT ALL. YOU PEOPLE FIND WAYS
TO GET AROUND WHAT YOU'VE DONE,
ACTUALLY, SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN
WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE FIRST
ITERATION OF THIS, BILL, WHICH
1701, WHICH MADE JOINT LIABILITY
FOR SUBCONTRACTOR CONTRACTOR
RELATIONSHIPS, BUT IT ONLY
INCLUDED WAGES, SO THERE WAS NO
PENALTIES ASSOCIATED. IT WASN'T
VERY EFFECTIVE, SENATOR LEYVA
CAME BACK A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER WITH SB 727. I'M QUITE
SURE SENATOR CORTEZ REMEMBERS
THAT, AND I'M PRETTY SURE YOU
REMEMBER THE OTHER STUFF, WHICH
ADDED PENALTIES AND FINES AS A
WAY TO ACTUALLY GET THEM TO DO
IT. NOW, WE'RE FINDING AND THE
JOINT LIABILITY WAS THERE. NOW
WE'RE FINDING THAT GENERAL
CONTRACTORS ARE AVOIDING THAT
JOINT LIABILITY BY SELF
PERFORMING IN JOBS THAT THEY
WOULDN'T NORMALLY SELF PERFORM.
THE OTHER ELEMENT THAT WAS NEW
AT THE TIME AND ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. AND YOU HEARD MORE
ABOUT IT TODAY, WAS IT ALSO
INCLUDED THE OUR STANDING AS
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES, WHICH IS THE
CONTRACTORS AND THE UNIONS
TOGETHER HAVE STANDING IN COURT
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS. YOU'RE
HEARING MORE ABOUT THAT NOW. AND
IT WAS MENTIONED, I THINK, A
COUPLE OF TIMES HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THE AUDIT SHOWED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IS A COMPLETELY
SWAMPED CONSTRUCTION, IS ONE OF
THE FOUR INDUSTRY RS THAT,
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS,
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY, WAGE THEFT
IS RAMPANT. SO THE ADDITION OF
THIS ABILITY TO DO SELF
ENFORCEMENT IS GOING TO BE MORE
AND MORE CRITICAL. AND WE ARE
JUST REALLY TESTING THE WHEELS
ON THIS OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT SOME OF THESE CONTRACTS ARE
FINDING ANOTHER WAY TO GET OUT
FROM THAT JOINT LIABILITY. YOUR
ODDS OF BEING INVESTIGATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ARE ONCE IN EVERY 300
YEARS. SO THERE'S LET'S ROLL THE
DICE AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS. THEY
MIGHT CATCH US IN 250 YEARS. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. PATTY
MCCARRAN IS THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR OUR ENFORCEMENT
ARM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS SHE CAN
ANSWER, THE ACTUAL TECHNICAL
STUFF, BUT I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK? IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. I
THINK YOU HAVE A SECOND. IS SHE
A TECHNICAL QUESTIONS? OH OH,
YEAH. PLEASE SHE'S YOUR
TECHNICAL WITNESS. PLEASE. OKAY.
I WASN'T SURE IF SHE WAS JUST
ANSWERING THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS, BUT PLEASE PROCEED.
AND IF YOU HAVE YOUR STATEMENT,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. OKAY.
THANK YOU, YES. MY NAME IS PATTY
MCCARRAN. I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR THE CARPENTERS
CONTRACTORS COOPERATION
COMMITTEE. WE'RE A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE THAT
INVESTIGATES, WAGE THEFT AND WE
GO ON THESE THE PRIVATE
PROJECTS. WE HAVE A HIGHLY
SKILLED, REPRESENTATIVES THAT GO
IN AND TALK TO WORKERS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE BEING PAID THE
PROPER WAGES AND CHECK THE
SAFETY VIOLATIONS AND WHATNOT.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN FINDING IS THAT
THAT, RECENTLY, MORE AND MORE,
THERE ARE GENERAL CONTRACTORS
WHO ARE NOT, ABIDING BY OR
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT PAYING
THEIR WORKERS WAGES, AND WE HAVE
NO STANDING, TO HELP REMEDY THIS
BECAUSE THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE SELF-PERFORMING GENERAL
CONTRACTORS. AND BASICALLY,
THAT'S IT. ESSENTIALLY IT. YEAH.
SO I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL,
OBVIOUSLY. THANK YOU. YEAH. AND
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. AND WE
WILL COME TO THE DAIS AFTER WE
ASK WHO ELSE IS IN THE AUDIENCE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
THANK YOU, MISS MCPHERSON. OKAY.
SEEING NO ONE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT TO
THE DAIS. SENATOR. SENATOR
LAIRD, I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY I
HAD TO PRESENT A BILL FOR FORMER
SPEAKER RENDON IN JUDICIARY, AND
I HAD NO NOTICE. SO CLEARLY, YOU
HAD SOME NOTICE HERE, AND I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. SENATOR LAIRD, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, YES.
JUST AGAIN, WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU TO
MY WITNESS, AND ON BEHALF OF,
SPEAKER MEREDITH ANTHONY RENDON,
WE THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND GOOD TO SEE YOU, MR.
CURTAIN. AND GOOD TO SEE WOMEN
HERE FROM THE FROM FROM THE
UNION. OKAY. SYSTEM PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB 2696. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I. GONZALEZ.
LAIRD LAIRD I. AT A VOTE OF 3 TO
0, THIS BILL IS ON CALL. TAKE IT
UP LATER. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS FOR THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT, AND WE'LL, BE BACK
SHORTLY. THANKS.
OKAY. LABOR COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 2374.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY. BEGIN
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, AB 2374 WILL
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S
DISPLACED JANITORS OPPORTUNITY
ACT BY EXPANDING PROTECTIONS FOR
LAID OFF JANITORS. IN 2002,
CALIFORNIA PASSED THE DISPLACED
JANITORS OPPORTUNITY ACT TO
PREVENT MASS LAYOFFS OF JANITORS
WHEN THERE WAS A CHANGE IN THE
STAFFING AGENCY AT THE SAME
FACILITY. IF A JANITORIAL
SERVICES CONTRACT IS TERMINATED,
THE ACT CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
LAID OFF JANITORS TO CONTINUE
WORKING IN THE SAME POSITION
UNDER THE NEW JANITORIAL
STAFFING AGENCY FOR 60 DAYS.
HOWEVER, THAT IS NO LONGER
ADEQUATE TIME FOR LAID OFF
WORKERS TO TRANSITION BETWEEN
JOBS. ADDITIONALLY THE RECENT
MASS LAYOFFS ACROSS ALL
INDUSTRIES HAVE EXPOSED OTHER
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE EXISTING
ACT. FOR EXAMPLE, ON DECEMBER
5TH, 2022, ECS FORMERLY KNOWN AS
TWITTER ENDED ITS 12 YEAR
CONTRACT WITH A JANITORIAL
AGENCY. THIS DECISION LEFT THOSE
JANITORS WITHOUT A JOB
OVERNIGHT. RIGHT BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS, ECS WAS ABLE TO
EXPLOIT THE LOOPHOLES IN THE
CURRENT LAW TO NOT PROVIDE THE
ADEQUATE TRANSITIONAL EMPLOYMENT
PERIOD TO THE LAID OFF JANITORS.
TO UPDATE THE JANITORS
OPPORTUNITY ACT TO ENSURE OUR
JANITORS ARE NOT BEING EXPLOITED
. THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE A NEWLY
HIRED JANITORIAL STAFFING AGENCY
TO RETAIN LAID OFF JANITORS FOR
90 DAYS, CLOSED LOOPHOLES IN THE
ACT BY REMOVING THE EXEMPTION
FOR JANITORIAL STAFFING AGENCIES
WITH LESS THAN 25 EMPLOYEES
REQUIRE COMPANIES TO RELAY
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR NEWLY
HIRED JANITORIAL STAFFING AGENCY
TO THE TERMINATED AGENCY. WE'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND HAVE AMENDED THE
BILL TO ADDRESS NEARLY ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS, AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I HAVE JANE BERNER FROM ON
BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL 87 WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU. I'M JIM
BRUNNER, I'M THE ATTORNEY FOR
THE JANITORS IN SAN FRANCISCO
WITH SEIU LOCAL 87. I'M NOT
GOING TO TRY TO REPEAT MUCH, BUT
WHAT HAPPENED IS, RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS IN 2022, THE JANITORS
FROM A UNION CONTRACTOR WERE
TERMINATED, AND ELON MUSK
BROUGHT IN A NEW CONTRACTOR, BUT
DID NOT FOLLOW STATE LAW. THEY
DID NOT TELL THE JANITORS THE
NAME OF THE NEW COMPANY, SO THE
JANITORS COULD NOT APPLY. HE
TRIED TO GET AROUND THE STATE
LAW BY KEEPING THAT JANITOR
COMPANY IN FOR 60 DAYS,
TERMINATED THEM, AND HIRED A NEW
CONTRACT THAT ALSO WAS NOT
UNION, AND DID NOT TELL THE
JANITORS. AGAIN ON WHO THE NEW
CONTRACTOR WAS, SO THE JANITORS
COULD NOT APPLY. THESE ARE
JANITORS WHO HAD BEEN WORKING IN
THAT INDUSTRY FOR ABOUT 12
YEARS, IN THE SAME BUILDING WITH
TWITTER BEFORE ELON MUSK TOOK
OVER, BECAUSE THEY HAD A UNION,
WE WERE ABLE TO SUE. BUT WE HAVE
LEARNED A LOT IN THAT SUIT ABOUT
HOW MUSK HAD GONE AROUND THE
STATE LAW AND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, AND THAT'S WHEN WE
STARTED WORKING WITH MATT TO TRY
TO GET THE BILL CHANGED SO THAT
WE CAN PROTECT SOME OF THESE
JANITORS IN THE FUTURE, ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHANGES IS THAT THE
LABOR COMMISSION WILL BE
MONITORING THIS. NOW. IT'S
REALLY HARD FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
JANITOR OR FIVE JANITORS TO SUE.
THEY COULD DO IT IF THEY HAVE A
UNION, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A
UNION. THEY CANNOT SUE. SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG CHANGES.
IT COVERS ALL JANITOR
CONTRACTORS. IT'S NOT JUST
PEOPLE WITH 25 EMPLOYEES,
BECAUSE THAT WAS ANOTHER THING.
HE GOT THE FIRST JANITOR COMPANY
THAT DIDN'T HAVE 25 EMPLOYEES TO
GET AROUND THE BILL, AND ADDS
MORE SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES. WE
WORKED REALLY CLOSELY WITH THE
CHAMBER. WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
CHANGES WORKING WITH THE CHAMBER
. WE HAVE. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONLY ONE ISSUE OPEN AND THAT IS
NOTICE WE AGREED WITH THE
CHAMBER THAT INSTEAD OF GIVING
THE NOTICE TO ALL THE JANITORS
INDIVIDUALLY IT AT THEIR
ADDRESS, THEY CAN POST IT IN A
BUILDING. BUT IF THE JANITORS
ARE NOT IN THE BUILDING ANYMORE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN LAID OFF.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN OUR
SITUATION RIGHT BEFORE CHRISTMAS
, THEY WERE LAID OFF AND THEY
WERE NOT IN THE BUILDING. THEN
WE'RE ASKING THAT THEY WRAP UP.
WE HAVE ONE 30S THEY WILL GIVE
THE JANITORS UNION NOTICE. SO
THE JANITORS KNOW WHO TO APPLY
FOR A JOB FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. STATE YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS SARA
FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT SHANE
GUZMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? PLEASE
STEP FORWARD, GOOD MORNING,
ASHLEY HOFFMAN, THE CAO CHAMBER,
WE ARE JUST IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. AS THE SPONSOR
INDICATED, JUST ONE TINY ISSUE
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO SEE IF
MAYBE WE CAN WORK ON, I JUST
CAN'T THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR ENOUGH FOR ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ABOUT
THIS BILL AND ALL THE
AMENDMENTS. SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COOPERATION ON THIS, SO WE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING TO SEE IF
THAT THAT ONE ISSUE, IF THERE'S
SOMETHING ON OUR END, WE CAN
PROPOSE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. CHAIR. SENATORS DEAN RAFEAL
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB 2374.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MICHELI, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED. AND FOR
BEN EBANKS, CLIENT, CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MARLON LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION, ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CAL CHAMBER.
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. SKYLER WONACOTT
WITH CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND BOMA,
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. OKAY. SEEING NO ONE ELSE AT
THE MIC, WE'LL MOVE TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR LAIRD. YEAH, I JUST HAD
ONE QUESTION, WHICH IS I LIKE
THE DIRECTION. I LIKE THE FACT
THAT EVERYBODY SAYS YOU'RE
WORKING AND YOU'RE CLOSE. YOU
SAID THERE WAS ONE ISSUE LEFT,
AND MY NOTES SHOWED A DIFFERENT
ISSUE. SO I WAS GOING TO ASK
ABOUT IT, WHICH IS THE ISSUE OF
AND I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE THE
AUTHOR IS TAKING IS THE ISSUE IS
THAT WHEN THE LIABILITY GOES TO
THE OWNER OF THE BUILDING AND
THE OWNER OF THE BUILDING HAS
SUBCONTRACTED OUT TO SOMEBODY
ELSE, THEY MIGHT NOT BE AWARE OF
THE OPERATIONS IN THE DISTRICT
IN THE BUILDING, BUT THEY'RE
ASSUMING THE LIABILITY. I HAD
HEARD THAT THAT WAS AN
OUTSTANDING ISSUE. HAS THAT
ISSUE BEEN RESOLVED IN SOME WAY?
I'M NOT SURE I'M FOLLOWING YOU.
SO YOU'RE SAYING A SUCCESS IN
THE MANAGER, THE AWARDING
AUTHORITY, A MANAGER OR THE
CONTRACTOR WHO MAY BE SUCCESSOR
CONTRACT? I'M NOT USING EITHER
TERM. I'M USING THE TERM THAT
THE OWNER OF THE BUILDING GETS
LIABILITY. THE OWNER OF THE
BUILDING SUBCONTRACTS TO SERVICE
AND IS NOT AWARE OF THE
OPERATIONS THAT ARE DONE BY THE
SUBCONTRACTOR, BUT THE OWNER
ACCEPTS THE LIABILITY, GETS THE
LIABILITY. I DON'T BELIEVE THE
OWNER GETS. IT'S WHOEVER WAS IN
THE CONTRACT WITH THE JANITORS
CONTRACTOR. IT'S NOT. SO IF THE
OWNER WASN'T IN THE CONTRACT,
THERE IS NO LIABILITY. WE HAD
THAT SITUATION BECAUSE WE HAD AN
OWNER THAT WAS VERY COOPERATIVE
AND WANTED TO WORK OUT WITH US,
BUT THEY WERE NOT IN THE
CONTRACT WITH THE JANITORS
CONTRACTOR. SO ANOTHER WAY OF
SAYING IT IS WHAT I SAID. IS IT
AN ISSUE? IT'S NOT AN ISSUE.
THANK YOU. I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ.
WONDERFUL. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR LAIRD. AND, YOU
KNOW, I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL.
WE KNOW WHEN WORKERS ARE
TERMINATED DUE TO A DISPLACEMENT
ISSUE, IT CAN RESULT IN
HOMELESSNESS AND COMPLETE
DESTABILIZATION. DESTABILIZATION
OF FAMILIES. AND SO A 90 DAY
SAFETY NET IS CERTAINLY ONE THAT
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO SEE IN
THIS BILL. SO THAT THAT
DISRUPTION DOESN'T HAPPEN AND
FAMILIES HAVE STABILITY THROUGH
THESE KINDS OF CONTRACT CHANGES.
SO I WANT TO REALLY RECOGNIZE
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE AND
THE CONTINUED WORK, IT SOUNDS
LIKE WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
THIS. SO WE HAVE A MOTION, BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, MR.
HANEY? YES THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND THANK YOU TO THE OPPOSITION
FOR WORKING WITH US AS WELL. THE
EARLY ON, THIS WAS ON THE JOB
KILLER LIST BECAUSE OF THE
LIABILITY ISSUE. AND WE WORKED
HARD WITH THEM TO ADDRESS IT AND
WAS TAKEN OFF. AND AS HAS BEEN
SAID, THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRESS.
AND WE ADDRESSED THOSE CONCERNS
AS WE WENT FORWARD. AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TALK WITH
FOLKS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF NOTICE.
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
PROTECT PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG BUT ARE IN RISK OF
BEING DISPLACED FROM THEIR JOBS,
SOME OF WHICH HAVE THEY'VE BEEN
FOR A LONG TIME. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ASSISTANT, WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE? WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAIRD ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 2374.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I. GONZALEZ LAIRD. LAIRD
I. OKAY. WE HAVE A VOTE OF 3 TO
0, AND THIS BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
RECESS AND RE CONVENE WHEN OUR
PRESENTER IS HERE.
OKAY. SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT HAS RECONVENED, AND I
SEE WE HAVE PRESENTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. WE WILL BE COVERING,
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
2448. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU
MAY PROCEED, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FIRST, I'D LIKE TO
THANK, YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND THE
COMMITTEE. WORKING WITH MYSELF
AND ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS WELL. SO WE WILL
BE ACCEPTING THOSE IN BRIEF, AB
2448 WOULD CREATE AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
ZONE, IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY, TO BE
MANAGED BY THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE AND DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY, TO CREATE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING JOBS AND EDUCATION
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES, WE ANTICIPATE
CONTINUING TO SPEND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, ON CONTINUING TO BUILD
OUT THE EV INFRASTRUCTURE AND EV
MANUFACTURING, AND WE MUST MAKE
SURE THAT, ALL COMMUNITIES,
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES, HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BENEFIT FROM THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT THESE THESE
EXPENDITURES ARE MAKING, WE'VE
WORKED WITH THIS COMMITTEE. SO
THIS BILL WILL NOW DIRECT THE
AGENCY TO COLLABORATE, WITH THE
COUNTY TO ASSIST IN DETERMINING
THE GEOGRAPHICAL BOUNDARIES OF
THE PROGRAM. THE IDEA IS, IF WE
CAN USE THIS AS A MODEL, THEN
THIS IS A MODEL WE CAN TAKE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES, AGAIN, A LOT OF OUR
, INNOVATION AND, MANUFACTURING
AND EVS ARE REALLY LOCATED IN
SELECT AND ARE USUALLY HIGHER
INCOME COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO DO THIS?
HOW CAN WE GET PEOPLE TRAINED TO
BE WELDERS, TO BE ABLE TO BE IN
THOSE FACTORIES? HOW DO HOW CAN
WE MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
COME FROM OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH A TRAINING OR CERTIFICATION
AND GO INTO THOSE THINGS WHERE
THEY CAN ACTUALLY PURCHASE AN
INCOME, THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
PURCHASE THEIR OWN HOMES WITH.
RIGHT? ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
SO IMPORTANT AND WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO, CREATE THE FRAMEWORK
FOR THESE THINGS TO BE TAKEN
STATEWIDE. AND SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE A
WITNESS WITH YOU HERE TODAY?
OKAY ANYONE HERE WANT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. THANK YOU. MA'AM,
DAVID QUINTANA, ON BEHALF OF
KAMA AUTO AUTOMOTIVE, AND, AMY,
AN EV MANUFACTURER WITH A BRAND
NEW FACILITY IN MORENO VALLEY.
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL? OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SEEING NONE. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
DAIS. MEMBERS MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
MOVED THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
TO SYSTEM, PLEASE. OH, YOU MUST
CLOSE. YOU MUST CLOSE. NO
PROBLEM, THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED,
UNANIMOUS AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GONZALEZ.
ASSISTANT. CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THE MOTION IS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
SENATOR CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LAIRD. ALL
RIGHT, THREE ZERO. WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THAT. WE HAVE A VOTE OF
3 TO 0. THE BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS. AND
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
CONSENT FILE ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
VOTED 4 TO 0 CONSENT. CALENDAR
IS STILL ON CALL. LET'S MOVE TO
FIVE. ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 2288.
MOVING IN. FILE. ORDER OF FILE.
ITEM ONE HAS A MOTION OF Dð.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. THE CHAIR IS VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE SORRY.
4401 OKAY. 4 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
STILL ON CALL. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
FIVE. ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 2602
FOR FILE. ITEM NUMBER TWO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK, SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE THAT'S A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS STILL ON CALL.
MOVING IN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 2374 FOR FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. THE CHAIR IS VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE OKAY.
THAT IS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0. THE
BILL IS ON CALL. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
2696 FOR FILE ITEM SIX. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK, SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. AND THAT IS A VOTE OF 4 TO
0. THAT BILL IS ON CALL. WE WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB 2873 ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE VOTED 4 TO 0. THE
BILL IS STILL ON CALL. LET'S
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB 2901 ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK. SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE 4 TO 0. THAT BILL IS ALSO ON
CALL.
OKAY. WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR, THAT IS AB 2448.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
THE CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK, SENATOR. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE
. VOTE OF 4 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
ON CALL.
ALRIGHT. WE UNDERSTAND. WELL, WE
ARE JUST GOING TO REOPEN THE
ROLL NOW AND START FROM OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS JUST FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE TODAY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR WILK WILK. AYE
5 TO 0. OKAY. WITH A VOTE OF 5
TO 0, THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT, AND THEN WE'LL START AT THE
TOP OF THE FILE ORDER, FILE ITEM
ONE. THE MOTIONS DO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. Kò.
SENATOR WILK NÓ WILK NÓ. OKAY.
WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 1, THAT BILL
IS OUT ON FILE ITEM TWO. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. THIS
IS AB 2602. SENATOR WILK WILK.
AYE 5 TO 0 WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO
0. THAT BILL IS OUT ON FILE ITEM
THREE AB 2374. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. SENATOR WILK NÓ WILK
NÓ. A VOTE OF 4 TO 1. THAT BILL
IS OUT ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
2448. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR.
SENATOR WILK, A WILK AYE. WITH A
VOTE OF 5 TO 0, THAT BILL IS OUT
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX. THE
MOTIONS DO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON THE JUDICIARY. SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR WILK NOT VOTING OF 4 TO
0. WE ARE OUT WITH A VOTE OF 4
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT FILE.IT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR WILK
WILK. AYE 5 TO 0. WE ARE ON WITH
A VOTE OF 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT AND ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR WILK A WILK. AYE 5 TO 0.
WE ARE OUT WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO
0. THAT BILL IS OUT. SO THAT
ENDS AND CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
FOR THE DAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GIVE ANY
COMMENT ON ANY ITEM THAT CAME
BEFORE US, FEEL FREE TO, PUT IT
IN WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE,
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
TIME. WE ARE ADJOURNED.